[Music]
when you talk about shireen you talk
about somebody whose presence is felt in
every home and heard in every home
she was fearless um
but she was also human and you know
there were times when she was scared um
when encountering you know uh difficult
situations
um the only difference was
is that um
she
she pulled through she pushed through
she was there in every town every
palestinian town village
[Music]
alleyway refugee camp everybody knew her
name everybody welcomed her
[Music]
she wanted to do the stories that nobody
else wanted to do um
and she uh gave a voice to a lot of
people who we otherwise wouldn't have
heard from a lot of women
grew up
i would say um
you know holding a
a hairbrush in front of a mirror and
pretending to be shitty and then being
like you know shirin
ramallah
and i know that a lot of women
want to follow in her footsteps
[Music]
everywhere we went people would stop her
in the street like wanting to take a
picture or wanting to take an autograph
and she would happily oblige
[Music]
like the rest of palestinian journalists
you know
she was targeted and
and
it's hard to do that job it's hard to
carry
um
carry that torch so to speak and
i think that shirin
did that very well and she paid for it
with her life
i remember during the height of the
second intifada like
israeli soldiers would go around
ramallah
and they would mimic her and they would
shout from a bull horn
her famous closing lines
shirina
and i just can't help but feel that
you know they
they took away that voice
[Music]
you